foreign
[Music]
cast number 18. welcome tonight and
thank you to Jocko willink Productions
we are able to bring this interview to
you live from North Carolina
and we thank tonight we have a special
guest a long time friend who I served
together with at CCN
and tonight we want to welcome Cletus
baby son send you to the show CLE
welcome to the show glad to be here I
was going to start the show out with uh
uh instead of having a really great War
Story which of which you've got many and
your history is so rich
um I was going to start out the story
with me leaving after my first Tour of
Duty you and I were both up on marble
Mountain I was on the one mountain
you're on the other one and you saw me
leaving it was my last day on my first
Tour of Duty I was leaving and you came
down and gave me a goodbye hug it's like
I took that hug home with me brother I
gotta tell you that
but uh more importantly
you have a unique history
and when I was at CCN and finally met
you in early 69 right you Dave Maurer
were two men that I held in the highest
esteem because on your right shoulder
path you had the first calf
and over time because you're both so
damn humble you wouldn't talk about it
much you were both in the first cab and
the Little Valley called the I drank
Valley in 1965 November and you went in
before the historic battle battles
thereafter as a scout
uh I was in a Pathfinder detection
that's the word actually it was the 11th
Pathfinder company the only
company-sized Pathfinder unit ever
deployed to combat
no yes so uh before we get into a couple
of your excellent stories from your days
as a 1-0 running recon at CCN I just am
obligated because few Americans know
they've seen a movie it's a great film
about the first major battle between
American forces and the North Vietnamese
Army
but you were there before the battle and
to this day it just blows my mind that
you and a couple of your fellow
Pathfinders were out there doing recon
prior to First historic Battle of that
major of the war itself so uh started a
little bit you landed there at the uh
outside of the um I drank Valley and
you're with that Pathfinder unit so talk
to us a little bit about that before we
get into your SOG story sir if you don't
mind we uh landed by ship at Queen Yon
South Vietnam and he took a ship over it
no ship a ship
and it was a 30 30 day cruise oh from
hell and not enough bathrooms not enough
deck space to work on your suntan no PT
no weapons oh we did PT oh is that right
we ran around the deck and we did target
practice off the fan tail of the ship
put barrels
on ropes and drop them off the back of
the ship and we'd we zeroed our new M16s
on those barrels now is that the M16 the
early verses with the three prongs at
the end before you find the flash with
pressure on it we took them out of the
box before we got on the bus at Fort
Benning Georgia
and took them out of the box left the
boxes in the dumpster there
loaded on the bus and left Charleston
uh
in August 14th of uh
1965. wow no kidding USS Darby Darby for
so for 30 days you flew across the
southeast Asia welcome so you landed
we're around Cameron Bay then no we
landed the ship we landed in uh quenjon
okay we went through the canal Zone to
Long Beach where they restocked the ship
refuel right now for a day or so and uh
no store leave or anything huh no no
but uh and then we
next stop what's going on no kidding
welcome to Vietnam yeah and uh we uh
were transported by Chinook helicopters
to unk
which is uh probably
200 miles Inland from Queen Yon
uh
to set up her base camp we had an
advanced party
uh at on K that had already cleared the
uh helicopter pad and there was a a
fixed-wing airstrip there but they had
already gone in and set that up for the
aircraft
and uh we
uh
slipped and put tents we had two men pup
tents and we slept in putt tent still
the GP mediums were shipped in from
queen young off the ship in a GP medium
can hold how many men well we
uh I'm sorry Comfort
we had a team each uh Pathfinder team
had a GP medium and there was a
uh 15 of us on each oh it's one of those
big tents yeah and it's canvas and it's
hotter than hell in the summertime oh
yes oh oh yes and you're down two
quarters that was two core or three that
was too cool okay yeah oh my God okay so
you're there at some point you're
getting used to now the other
interesting aspect of this story with
you in Vietnam was the fact that at some
point just for the hell of it you were
kind of bored you rode as the first door
gunner in the first cab with your M16
before the m60s or mini guns or rocket
pods or anything is that before or after
the battle of I drank Valley this is all
before the first cow went operational
uh somehow in the great scheme of things
they hadn't thought about having anyone
in the helicopter to shoot back so uh
uh Bruce criminal major criminal he was
just for the record Bruce I got my Medal
of Honor later than anybody else but I
got it Crandall right from the first
calf and if you've seen the movie We
Were Soldiers once
you'll see his portrayal which was I
forget the actor's name but he did a
hell of a job but I was his uh first
organer at first they're going to win
the M16 M16 and what he was doing he was
the 101st uh Airborne was pulling
security for the first Cavalry division
on their perimeter
uh until no we could uh get a division
base camp set up okay and uh
for the first time he moved the 101st
from one Patrol spot they moved them
every day right to keep confusion for
the any attacks it might indeed so this
is the 101st Airborne Division did base
security for the first cow I just wanted
to make sure I heard that correctly
that's correct okay moving right along
with this story sir but uh uh Colonel
Crandall got shot at the First first day
that he was moving the security around
yeah and he came back to the aviation
Commander Colonel Burdette and told him
that uh he needed someone sitting in
that aircraft
shooting back when he was receiving fire
and uh
they came to the Pathfinder company and
asked for volunteers
uh to fly a door gunner and we were
digging stumps and uh
clearing parameter and of course
concertina wire and all this stuff and
the products were very employed with
that but uh the volunteer thing uh
seemed like a good idea so several of us
volunteered that's one of the first the
only times you ever ever other than SOG
it's one of the few times you volunt you
failed to follow the first rule of the
army never volunteer for anything
uh fortunately I got Colonel a major
Crandall
I was selected for his door gunner and
my buddy uh
I can't uh he'll come to you but we'll
get back to him but anyway my buddy uh
flew for uh Ed Freeman
really he was called too tall to fly
because he was over by he's around six
eight right and uh he was he was
disqualified by medical standards
because of his height to fly but somehow
it worked out that he was uh
the weighing man and again just for the
record we have to point out that free Mr
Freeman received his Medal of Honor in a
timely fashion that's true my God what
history but uh we flew I I all of us had
our uh
uh
air metal before the first cow the air
metal with a V device probably because
you guys were no I was well it was just
air Metals in the air metal there's no
sure I don't think there's a v on it but
okay but uh you have to have at least 16
at that time you had to have 16 uh
solves into an LC before you could
receive right I remember with us we had
to keep a log right before you could
even be put in for the metal right oh my
God but the pool we ever went
operational yeah all of us had received
you were there already right
it was uh
uh trying times but they we found out
the first flight that the M16s were not
going to work because chatter changed
magazines yeah and we taped the
magazines together where we have three
and we'd rotate them three that didn't
work
no kidding but okay
that uh that's 60 rounds of ammo so uh
60 rounds if you're 54 because you're
only doing two keeping two out right in
the mag right so the Springs don't break
on you yeah
yeah but uh you know what technically
yes indeed but uh we uh discussed what
we were going to do and we suggested
do a major Criminal that we attach the
G13 parachute cord to the roof of the
aircraft with a clip
hanging down the handle carrying handle
on an M60 machine gun fit right into the
snap link of the
parachute cord
and yeah that's what we used from there
after from there after we had a 50
caliber ammo box that were Linked UP
7.62 ammo for the machine gun we could
have three to five thousand rounds of
ammo wow that Linked UP ready for flight
so
that's what we used so even in the early
part of War I assume there's time you
went through quite a few rounds oh yes
several several boxes yeah this is all
before the infamous Battle of the I
drank Valley before the uh first cow
went operation so while you're earning
your air metal flying with him at some
point
the CEO or whoever you're commanding
officer ncoic was said hey we
Pathfinders we got a mission in this
Valley
what was that like getting that marching
orders and then
actually going out what was your uh I
mean I I think I know what it would be
but it's better hearing it from the man
who was on the ground
really uh it was just a part of the job
we're going back from door gunner you're
too modest to what we were trying to do
yeah you're doing your door cutter he
was like a volunteer to get off sandbag
duty but you're still out there which is
during our time we between us Ground
Pounders they said that door Gunners by
67 and 68 their life expectancy was five
to ten minutes true in a combat zone
true so here you are just in your spare
time fighting those kind of odds and
some of the time they said here run this
Mission which at the time did you have
any intel reports at all about the NVA
division or Battalion or whatever the
hell it was that was there already no
that was way north of where we were
really that was yeah up at uh pleco okay
in that area and uh
we had no idea we were just protecting
the division area and making milk runs
for the 101st and carrying food out to
the Troops and uh and so then it comes
around it's time for the Pathfinder to
hit the ground prior to the I drank
Valley
the insertion of the troops there by
that time they had trained uh door
Gunners they had door mounts in the
helicopters uh ready for the door
Gunners that were trained and they come
in and took the mission and we went back
to doing our Pathfinder duties which was
to set up Landing zones and direct
aircraft when they were coming into the
landing zones right so you were on the
ground for how many days before the
actual assault occurs because you're
down there just you with a two-man team
I'm not familiar how the Pathfinders
worked it was usually uh it was either
you could be in 30 minutes before the
aircraft they actually they drop you off
30 minutes before or you could be
overnight right uh so in this case
you're in there you clear dlz's you're
bringing helicopters in the [__] hits
the fan are you still there what
capacity how's your roll changed at that
point we still control that LZ until the
Infantry uh
moves out doing their uh mission
uh patrolling sure and uh looking for
the enemy and at that point uh
you ready to move with the Infantry
company
or Battalion or whatever size the unit
is you move with them
are your pull back
and uh
set up another LZ somewhere else they'll
right well they're going to need to move
troops to so you're busy there for a
while because then they had a second
battle in the third battle which was
just horrific in nature well really the
uh combat portion of it started uh at
the play me Special Forces Camp that's
where it all began that's where it all
began because they uh they were trying
to overrun play me Special Forces camp
and uh the first cow was uh
I think that was a
second of the fifth in the first to the
12th
uh Calvary that went in to play me lz's
outside to play me
and we were setting up lz's for those
units those two battalions to come in so
a lot of uh
Pathfinders were busy we Hopscotch for
those infantry troops down the valley
ah
I can't remember how many LCS but I was
I was only on uh
one or two lz's uh because we alternated
Pathfinders and I went back to the rear
area to uh
uh Camp Holloway at playku that's where
we were staged and uh
uh I was redirected to uh
me and two other Pathfinders were
directed to the turkey farm that's what
Turkey Farm that's what it was called
Turkey Farm controllers our call sign
but it was a Tea Plantation owned by a
French
uh farmer of course and uh who paid
bribes for the VCS they wouldn't mess
with his tea they
right and protected him he was willing
because we're protecting him from the
NBA because they're in that Valley and
uh we were like uh 30 miles from the
mountain where the LG x-ray was finally
set up right but uh we uh hopped Scotch
from uh played
uh play me Special Forces Camp down to
uh
before the mountain
before we got anywhere near lcx right we
broke contact and pulled us uh other two
uh battalions out
and uh it was a week or so later when
the seventh calf went into LZ x-ray
wow and uh I wasn't a part of that I was
running the resupply point which was
that Airfield uh at the Tea Plantation
and that was no that was no Cakewalk
because when you're coming in and out
you guys were getting hammered well uh
one night we watched the uh VC
uh come down the side of the Airfield we
we didn't go inside the perimeter where
the uh
first to the fifth and the second of the
12th were
brought back to before right
after they finished their battle they uh
recovered there and uh
we were
sitting there one night we stayed out on
the Airfield instead of going back to
where the secure area we'd stay there at
night and uh be a Pathfinder and all
just keep an eye on things just uh
somebody stayed awake all night but yeah
there was aircraft would come in at
night too but uh we uh one night we
watched the VC come down the far side of
the Airfield and attack the uh
Supply
Depot at the Tea Plantation no and we
just stayed low and
let what happened happened
but uh so at some point that all wrapped
up you come back to the states is there
anything else exciting during that first
Tour of Duty because that's just an
incredible experience in the early part
of the war to be there at that phase for
that battle and then you had your tour
Duty with the first calf at some point
you hear about learn about smell about
Special Forces and you say someday I
want to be a Green Beret
School uh the idea formulated because uh
Charlie Gray uh Charlie Charlie Gray
who's a future song guy indeed uh
was in Jump School in our class and uh
Charlie had
uh come out of Korea
to go to special forces training and he
had to go to jump school but he was a he
was a senior guy in our barracks uh and
nobody messed with Charlie nobody knows
what y'all but now he he was uh
uh
it would really helped us out a lot but
he taught us a lot he wasn't overbearing
with his leadership but he he was big
enough to influence and back it up
or just kick your ass if you got out of
the line but when we graduated when we
graded to Michael from jump school he uh
last time I saw him and jump school he
was leaving with two guys with Green
Beret on and
I you know it
kind of uh formed up in the back of my
mind sure and and
uh you do your tour of Duty you come
back and meanwhile you're thinking in
the back of your mind you being the big
thinker that you were at that time I was
when I came back from Vietnam uh in June
late June July of uh 66.
I was assigned to the 82nd Airborne
Division and just down the street from
Green Berets right yes and uh I served
as a squad leader uh in the uh 82nd for
two years
really re-enlisted for Special Forces
wow so uh
uh
January
2nd of January we started our class
and most of us were combat veterans that
were in that class Larry trouble was one
in the class
there were several that went to SOG that
were in that class of Special Forces we
were all weapons sure class but uh the
boy toy class they uh they uh
brought in some privates
like John plaster was one uh uh the baby
SF program was kicking in Gilmer uh
there there was just a number of them
that were in our mli sure and John L
plaster just happens to be song cast
number 10 for those in the audience who
might be interested some days dial in
but uh yes I'm sorry go ahead sir but uh
we uh
uh
started in my MRI and uh our instructor
was uh
uh Mark Mo really more Worley in your
MOS class and how how did he teach his
class because that he just I'll never
forget that story he was method of
method of instruction and he was one of
the best instructors I think that that
I've ever known sure but uh he was in a
cast a body cast from his waist up his
arm had a Broad Run running from right
his arm to his shoulder and it was cast
solid his left arm was free
but he could pick his nose and wipe
himself
that's about it but he he was so
impressed I was so impressed because
this guy
injured that way already back working
giving methods of instruction to a bunch
of new SF guys
oh my God talk about living legends and
again the injuries he acquired was on a
SOG recon mission I had no idea until
later many years later because he's so
humble he never talked about it right
yeah I had no idea until later oh my God
yeah so Mo Morris Moe Worley the first
the one and the only he uh we uh
finished a method of instructions and
then the uh
we went to the field exercise after the
field exercise
we went into the weapons class well no
Worley showed up as an instructor in the
weapons class
and uh
he had his cast off and he was he was
somewhat back to normal
and uh
he was even better instructor because
he's recovered in front of his injuries
but uh
he he really made a lasted impression on
me and I didn't find out till uh after I
went to song that he had actually
gotten injured out of uh Contin
wow and
so you finally get through it all you
graduate do the FTX your final FTX Phase
two
at some point which would be what time
do you get did you get the leave prior
to going to Vietnam yes uh I I took a
30-day leave uh home and I took my
family back to Alabama and set them up
got them got the children in school
and left left for a bit now and when was
this this was all that stuff
66. no kidding wow
so you returned to Vietnam and where do
you where's your first assignment then
we had uh out of uh
training group we had direct orders
there was 12 of us uh that had orders
directly
two uh sock really yes
to form an alarm they couldn't
they were diverting ncos at Cameron Bay
to the Infantry outfit whether you had a
beret or not at that time
but they couldn't do it because we was
under the department of army orders
to be directly to suck yeah because by
60 this is 67 you said
yeah so they're looking by the time
anybody with combat experience it would
be 67 wait a minute wait a minute no no
because you landed there came home in 66
did your trainings would be 67. it'd be
we finished in January of we started
weapons training January 68. there we go
now we're back on track sure now 68. uh
we graduated in July
Late July of 68. and our order supposed
to be in uh
uh Cameron Bay report to the train in
Fort Lewis by August August uh whatever
but you're there
now from there you go in the train a
little in-country training you get your
in-country training for three weeks we
had no one concert trying no because you
had to direct orders well
they held us up and they said they were
processing us I don't know why they held
us up but on uh
August
24th the morning of August 24th
uh somebody come running over to the
tent so right now you're in the train
you've arrived from the states you're in
the train at the base camp for all SF
operations fifth group headquarters so
it's August 24th 1968 right or may have
been the 23rd because the attack was in
the morning and they came in for hey but
take it from there because this is the
historic battle Danang okay uh 23rd the
attack was the nine of the 23rd it was
the morning like midnight goes past so
they hit around one or two o'clock in
the morning okay and then they need a
reaction so it was the morning of the
24th that the attack actually occurred
no the 23rd is the morning of the 23rd
attack and then you went up that that's
when you got the word about the attack
it was the 23rd that we got yes sir yeah
because you react is there like a
reaction for us from the train right so
but again this is what's unique about
your story you landed the triang which
is the base you're going to I get some
in country trading instead
it's August 23rd where there was an NBA
sapper attack at fob4 in Danae where
they killed 16 Green Berets to this day
the most historic tragic loss of Green
Berets in one day and they need a
reaction for us with Cloud they turn to
you guys to go go to design fob4 you're
reported in there instead of getting any
in-country trade of course you're a
combat vet so you'd be cool not to worry
but welcome to the secret War you report
to fob4 and coming down Highway One what
was that like walking into that base
after that tremendous unbelievable
battle if you remember the old bus and
we had the old
school bus
that picked us up at the airport
we got on the Blackbird and we couldn't
understand the camouflage green and
black yeah so in the chaircraft yeah I
can see us we really hadn't dawned on us
really what we were getting into
and uh we uh
we're on the bus and we're going through
the front gate
of fob4 and I'm thinking
uh one strand of concertina wire
around the front of that compound all
the way to the back to the beach it was
all that was between the NBA po camp and
well the Pow Camp was completely secure
because they had strands and strands at
our base at fob4 at the time
you were underwhelmed with the security
you saw absolutely I mean just on the
bus yeah before I even got off and saw
so at this point we're une4 E5 that was
an 85 oh you had all that rank
I forgot what what a powerful dude you
were oh yeah
so Sergeant senior arrives you come on
base and welcome to the secret War
well we didn't know it was a sacred War
yet okay they were too busy you're too
busy reacting recovering
we helped we helped in recovering the
count uh
the way the setup security finally I
guess because recline company had the uh
security
posted along the beach area and they got
a little more serious about it then yes
we were actually they had posts along
that and we started digging trenches so
just for our listeners who might be
coming into episode
17 here for the first time
um
fob4 was on the beach in China Beach and
Danang it was in the South part of
Danang and it was a top secret base and
had been hit by a sapper attack and
um the security at the beach had been
lacking but the the attack was took over
a year for them to plan they hit at
night
they had sappers that came in wearing
headbands that said we came here to die
they did plenty of them
and for several hours there was like
sheer hell on that during that night
we've interviewed Larry Trimble in the
earlier sawcast he was on the mountain
who took out the mortar units had they
not there would have been far more
casualties and uh so you come in and
there's still the the bases on fire
different places buildings are smoking
they're picking up our wounded
everywhere back to you sir because
you're the man walking into this picture
well it's it it was shocking
but uh believable because of the lack of
security and uh
uh I was concerned it didn't bother me
too much to be out there
setting up new security
the guy that came in with us was a staff
sergeant Morgan
he
was put he was given he was an engineer
and he was given the responsibility he
didn't come out of training group he was
just a part of a group that was on of
our group that was on orders to come to
soccer right but uh he was given the
responsibility for setting off the
Minefield the barbed wire all the
obstacles of the new defense parameter
and that was his sole responsibility
and they gave him details of uh indeeds
or whatever Americans whoever could get
or
they could get to help him right and
they built another Tower the Seabees
come in and built another
guard Tower down on the beach side of
the uh parameter and then they prepared
to damage to the com center right and
the new talk was damaged but it
withstood the uh the attack but they
built a they actually reinforced all of
it except the uh uh
S1 building the uh
Camp headquarters
but uh
Larry Trimble by the way was in my uh
weapons class no he graduated from
special forces training in the same
little did you know Larry is up on the
mountains
until he came down until he came down he
came down and I think they replaced him
with another team a few days later but
he had that little issue of his ditched
leaving him he was a Lone Ranger for a
while
yeah but oh God but uh that was a
it was a couple of days before uh
Colonel Warren called the new
Replacements into his office and uh
uh we were sitting there waiting for him
and he walked into the office
and uh introduced himself and grew up at
sea at the headquarters Upstate of
course and in the Commander's office and
uh oh really yes well you got the big
briefing oh yeah
but uh he uh
he's welcomed us
to see and see
and he said
uh I've got to show you this map and he
opened the map
it was a plywood cover for the mountain
he opened the doors to the mouth
and uh
he had the map of Vietnam there was a
red line
down through the Vietnam border
and he said you're living here at Danang
and he pointed to the map to denying
you're living here this is your home
your job if you stay here will be over
here
over across defense over the red line
yeah and he said uh Indian Territory he
closed them out
and said those of you who are
don't want to be a part of that
operation needs to leave now
and uh nobody got up
then they uh
brought out the uh non non-disclosure
agreements yes agreement and uh you
can't talk to anybody for 20 years if
you do we will prosecute you federally
right and then he uh broke us down most
of us went to Recon company and uh a few
Hatchet Force but uh
most of us and uh
uh
welcome to rickon
I would say uh sent to our team moccasin
at that time it was St right because
there were STS until January 1st and
they changed everything to RTS because
right they figured the bad guys knew
what the STS were RTS but they uh
I was on
Estee moccasin with uh
who was uh Lonnie Stone Lonnie Stone was
a Sergeant First Class he had no combat
experience but he was
the team leader yeah RT or SD Marx this
is after the attack they lost a lot of
people people there I don't know how
many people they lost for the Recon
company I know they lost a few I I I'm
not sure how many but there was a good
number oh yeah but uh
uh
we started training and uh
I started learning the ropes all the
movements and
uh breaking contact and it was moccasin
a yard Monty art team or Vietnam it was
Vietnamese okay how's your how's your
when you got introduced and it must have
been happy because you're like the same
height as they were well it was yeah it
was it was it was fun I mean uh it
wasn't like my meeting with my zero one
you looked at me and goes you you feed
it too big you're too tall and you look
stupid I wouldn't say I fit in better
you're much better
plus you were a combat vet yeah they
they knew what a combat patch was and by
that time everybody knew what the first
Cav had been through in that Valley of
Hell well we've uh went through a
training cycle and uh
they sent us on our first mission was to
Bam it to it to CCS really and our
mission at that times that would be five
right yeah and uh
we were given a mission of a pow snatch
and
briefed and debriefed and uh
our mission was planned to go in the
next day at uh five o'clock we would fly
and you were flying to Cambodia we were
flying North to the fishhook oh official
care okay and and for our listeners the
physical carry was layoffs Cambodia and
Vietnam right and there were so many
several infiltration routes into South
Vietnam for there which was a major area
of contention for fob 2 and 5 which
later became CCS right and we lost some
major teams in there right and uh We've
uh
the night before we uh was to insert
a guy kept riding the motorcycle up down
the hallway of the
Barracks we were staying in and I kept
telling uh London Stone I said so are
you the
you're the team leader you need to go
out there and stop that guy so we got
some rest and he wouldn't do it and
finally I got up I walked out in the
hallway
and uh the guy come down the hallway and
he stopped
the motorcycle right there at my legs
and he said can I help you and I said
you sure could if you please turn that
motorcycle off and
uh stop running it up down this Hall so
we can get some rest we're launching at
five o'clock in the morning I'd sure
appreciate it he said you got it
and he uh turned the motorcycle off and
pushed it out little did I know until
later it was Mad Dog's driver no the
legend of
CCS probably on song indeed and we have
a book coming out soon that we'll talk
about in a few future episodes here but
yes Mad Dog Jerry AKA Mad Dog Shriver
appropriately named
a great moniker for that and that was
riding the motorcycle
oh my God what a small world
yeah so you finally launched and had the
launch you said you're going to launch
late in the day for a reason earlier
okay early man thank you and daylight we
flew we got in inserted early in the
morning it was probably seven
seven or eight o'clock before we
actually hit the uh Landings on insert
and uh we moved for a couple of days
and we came up on a trail so let me just
hold you up for a second the the that
area
that area of operations what was the
canopy like were you in double triple
canopy or was it like because it was by
that time there's been some significant
bombing and Napalm runs we didn't see
any uh
uh it was just jungle it will uh triple
canopy
not really not like not liking Laos
right it was uh it was just jungle it
wasn't double canopy okay yeah sure
and uh moving was okay you know you
gotta wait a minute Vine here and there
but uh not thick like like flowers like
I found later but uh we moved for a
couple of days and we're moving slow and
easy and we came up on the trail
and we found a bamboo frame
for maybe a battalion size
Force
in the along the trail
and
uh
Lonnie Stone
left me
and the end is there along the trail and
we were looking for a prisoner who was
supposed to make a prisoner snack sure
and
he said I'm going to go up here and
photograph this billboard area and he
did and while he was gone up the trail
comes uh
a man in the uniform
will the Nike Poland stock AK over his
shoulder whistling whistling whistling
was he Whistling Dixie
that looks like it was Nixon but singing
the hoagie man the Ho Chi Minh but he uh
uh
he was far enough down the trail
until I had time to set the team up who
was going to grab the legs he was going
to grab the arms and I had the silence
pistol I was going to shoot the 22
standings
I was going to shoot him before he yes
and where were you going to shoot him
just our audiences
yeah but uh and so maybe he wouldn't put
up too much fire and uh
Stone
came back to the group
right in the middle of you're looking at
your potential pow for watching now
the Indians are watching and I'm
conversing with stone telling them
what's going on and
I said uh we've got a guy coming up the
trail we're prepared to take him and uh
he said uh we don't have time I've got
helicopters on a short final
and I said Lonnie that's perfect
yeah it's perfect hey I said where's the
LZ he said just down the hill over the
trail
I said we need to snatch this guy we can
have him down on it else shoot him pack
him up and take them home and uh
he said no and uh
he was at one zero oh yeah and
excellent opportunity and I could just
see that trip home after being there
because you're already thinking about
your bonus and your honor so what'd you
think about where's your RNR going to be
if you get this pill it doesn't get it
back to your life
[Music]
we had to get down because the guy was
getting close enough now so he whistled
on up the trail
and uh as soon as he got out of sight
we booked for the
uh
LZ and
we were there waiting on the helicopters
when they sat down oh my God but it was
so close but yet so far away the end
days were more upset than I was
they were upset because they knew what
the deal was
they knew I knew there was going to be a
reward if we absolutely yeah of course
they were very up so yeah they forever
we flew
uh
back they dropped us on top of I guess
that's cool rock mountain that's at the
fish hook I can't remember the correct
way North by case okay that's not cool
rock but there's another large mountain
thing is this is your mission they take
you to the top of this mountain and then
after the debris was after the debris
was black and Bama to it really they
debrief us and they sound Us North
back to that mountain and uh we put
played uh radio relay for other teams
for a couple of weeks before we uh came
back to Batman toy
and uh we came back to after the radio
today we uh
uh came back to Bama to it and caught a
uh
123 back to the name right so that was
the on that breed of relay side was that
where the Kings would take in set the
one wheel down you jump out the door
we uh
yeah
only uh you talk about on the mound yes
sir yeah
they dropped us off by helicopters and
then they picked us up a helicopter kind
of like marble mile yeah sure but only
it's just a single Peak but uh
uh we did it was cool there's nothing no
action no wow no uh
so you go back and uh we'll go back to
Obama to it and back to Danae
and I take Lonnie
uh off the 1-0 spot
and
I guess I'll become the one zero of RT
moccasin or St Marks yeah because you
had combat experience you've been across
the fence and uh and you would have had
a PO
em
first mission indeed yeah
your cherry missing on top of that oh my
God but uh
uh they put Lonnie flying Covey uh
that's I still don't understand that
move either but uh well rank has this
privileges sometimes which is I guess
the rule is supposed to be experienced
first but sometimes because of rank and
we've seen other examples of where that
let us astray that's your case you
become the one zero so at that point
welcome to uh one zero
status uh uh we had a gas people that
came in and skiba become the 1-1
and he had no combat experience either
and before we ran another mission
galberg
was on Larry trammell's team gabbard had
gone through special forces training
with me too
and uh
he had
come over on the flying with me
to uh
as part of your crying yeah as part of
the group
but he was on trumbull's team
and uh
tremble transferred to ASP I think
and uh when he transferred to ask that
left the one zero spot open and gabbard
told me he said I don't want to be a 1-0
I want you to come over and do the one
zero
and I thought about it for a day or two
and uh
Gilbert and I talked some more and I
decided to move over to rattler no
kidding and uh that's a pretty good team
yes it was after Larry trained him up a
little further you've picked up a team
that has a Vietnamese team right and the
uh the Vietnamese interpreter could
speak better than English than I could
no southern accent right no well he had
a French accent
but uh he uh
uh
I didn't trust him really from the
beginning because he he we conversed and
uh
he told me I asked him I said
where did you get all your education
that you can speak such fluent English
and he said uh
I went to college in France
and that made me a little nervous
because
I'm thinking that uh
uh
we knew other Vietnamese like Ho Chi
Minh who had gone to France for
Education
they had a very very strong communist uh
power base there but I wrestled with
that for several days
and you know we did our training and PT
and
uh
rifle fire and all that so what did it
feel like to be the 1-0 at that point I
mean after what you'd been through
already you had one Mission successful
well you got the film back he was happy
about that it could have been better but
welcome to the 1-0 I mean I just walking
into that and then go to a new team to
me it was no different than being a
squad leader in the 82nd Airborne
Division except you're doing it within
the indigenous and uh the only
difference you had an interpreter who
may be hinky or maybe not exactly that
was my biggest concern sure and uh
one day uh they come a knock at the door
of the hooch and I walk out and there's
a mountain or standing there with 11
Compadres
uh
saying we won't
you to Recon team
and I sat down on the step and
tried to understand what he was trying
to tell me and he said we want to be a
Recon team we want you to be our leader
and uh
I called Albert out of the hooch and he
sat down we talked with him and uh
I told uh
the leader he had introduced himself his
name was two
t-h-i-e-u to uh
I told him I said uh if you'll come back
tomorrow afternoon the same time
we'll tell you what we're gonna do
really and he said uh okay and they the
Mountain hours moved back to the hatchet
Force area
and Gilbert and I talked it over
you know for 24 hours and
we decided that would be a
excellent move they picked us they had
no kidding they picked us we didn't pick
them
and with all the other stuff that went
on with the Vietnamese deal
uh and feeling hinky about your
interpreter I mean after the zero one in
some ways The Interpreter is more
important because that's every
connection any kind of communication at
all with your little people is critical
right and he could just say one or two
words wrong and you're screwed right
wow
but uh so what became your new team what
was the name of that team that you
formed up there with your yards that
came to you it was RT Rattler
we were replaced the Vietnamese no kids
the mountain range I took him to S1 they
transferred the uh
uh
the Mountain Arts to the Recon company
and they tried I don't know
I I don't know what they did with the
vehicle you don't care they were gone
out a year they were gone they were gone
but uh
and
really in retrospect that's the best
thing that I could have ever done or
galbert and I could have ever done well
we did it as
it wasn't my decision it was our
decision but you two had your report it
goes back so you knew each other really
well there's no issue of trust there and
he had already proven himself so you
knew you had a good man when you're on
the ground you're not worried about your
back with him he was on my team
at uh McCall
which is chemical for final year FTX
training which is the final phase of
training of Special Forces but uh we had
gone through all that he would have gone
through weapons training with me so I
knew him and uh we had talked a lot
during training sure and uh
it just jailed and it really
it's the best thing that could have
happened to either one of us
that was a good team yeah you guys have
been some good missions out of there we
did we had some good missions we ran uh
six six missions
we only had one injury uh Kia got shot
through the hand we got in an ambush
uh we went on a mission
and you're not going to believe this big
seed
the S1 I don't know where you ever knew
him no no I don't remember the name I'm
sorry that's before Mike coming to down
to Danae ah
Captain Nicholson right just yeah he was
the yes one officer yeah he's the S one
who never went to the field who wrote a
book saying look at me and a Master
Sergeant William
oh I don't remember him okay uh I don't
know where it came from
and I don't know where he went there's
declared when he was gone but while we
were not in on the mission
and uh
when we hit the LZ
uh
my Recon team
was the only Recon team on that hatchet
force and that's on so you're attached
to a hazard Force you're the first guys
on the ground before they come in right
and then you're like a quick reaction
force if they've run into any trouble
or it is yeah and uh which is not an
easy assignment that is tough no and I
I hadn't expected anything like that
because I thought we were going to just
do Recon do Recon do your job right and
I've babysit a Hatcher for not babies
I'm being cruel here but be attached to
it Hatcher for us in the hostile
territory and if they get into the [__]
who's going to respond first your team
but we uh hit the ground
and uh
it got formed up
uh
and we start movement and just as we
start movement
guy in Black pajamas ran off the LZ
off the LZ and uh
two raised his rifle
to shoot him and I I pushed the barrel
down I told him let him go
and we started moving
and I got galbert to take half the team
to the rear of the hatchet Force company
and I took the point then you guys would
be talking back and forth in New York
Times I told uh Gilbert I said uh
when we when we removed maybe a a click
a kilometer away from the LZ I told him
to start putting out toe poppers the
little m14s that could Bluff your toes
when you step on them but uh and we
moved on and he was he was doing it and
uh
everybody had cleared uh into an opening
like a bomb bummed out area it wasn't
B-52s but it was cleaned out by bombs so
no brush just a little light brush but
it was all open
but just as we uh
hit the tree line on the other side of
the bomb area the toe poppers started
going off there's one went off
and then a
few minutes another one went off
and uh thank you Mr Garrett yes indeed
he was doing his job and I think too
Remembered at the time that I pushed
that barrel down that what I had in mind
to do but uh and it worked I know at
that point that there would be nobody
behind us
and
for a while yeah at least for a give you
a while to get used to your age I could
concentrate on the front and the sides
and with Gabbert in the back you'd have
to worry about your rear right wow but
uh
we moved through the clearing
there's no leadership
for the hatchet Force
uh none easily recognizable by the Recon
team no no kidding and
we uh
come off the mountain down into a creek
bed
our mission was to find an oil line that
was trying to figure out the first
pipeline that we heard about this is at
the end of 68 or early 69 now
this is early early 69.
wait a minute 68
68. we had the campus we shut down we
shut down from October to January
of 68 right no Recon missions were run
during that time
I don't I'm sure you were that same
thing because I know we we ran our ass
off okay well we were sure I don't know
why they shut us down from running any
Recon missions so it was early six to
nine when in 69 we were running that's
where we came down to CCN like the
middle of January 69. all right we met
for the first time right maybe in the
clubhouse January uh first we had a
Recon team inserted and we inserted aft
with that hatchet Force we uh inserted
after the hall housing mcgibbon which
was another team that insured up north
out of fob 1 at the time right sorted in
got hit at first late on New Year's Day
January 1st right three Americans at Kia
the indige Escape
and the whole psychological impact of of
that sapper attack on that team but uh
that that put a shot throughout
sure because Sparta Parks have flown out
he was flying coffee at the time we went
out get a comma check at midnight
and then it came back in the morning
no comma but uh
uh got back to the man it was after that
right that we took the a hatchet force
in with our first mission with the
mountain yards
and but we were moving off and we hit
that Creek bed and a noun Bush opened up
and
uh Kia was my point man and he opened
fire and I opened fire and the two in
Dish behind us opened up fire well I'm
expecting a hatchet Force to deploy into
the ambush
it didn't happen
but uh
so uh so did they do the DD mail I just
didn't get up and go the other way
they just stayed in place
they didn't move
I told uh
I'm radioed Gilbert I I told him pick up
the toe poppers
and move back up the mountain
and take the hatchet force in the rear
with you
and he did that and we started moving we
backed out of the ambush
which is totally
without any casualties
oh Kia got hit in the hand so he's Pat
you passed him up
but a grain bandage around his hand and
continue to March okay but uh
we uh wheeled through
no further contact
we got back on the
when I cleared uh the trees and into the
clearing
uh Houston
Captain Nicholson and uh
Master Sergeant Webb were sitting
huddled together in the center
of that opening no and the end is where
everywhere
so I told Gilbert I said you start on
one side put these uh in dudes
and uh uh defensive defensive uh
position sure parameter and he did and
uh
London Stone come up on the radio after
we've made contact I'm after I come out
I've made contact with the Covey yeah
and told him what was going on
and I told him we're low of ammo
we need uh
resupply of Elmo so you had a sense of
contact you're you're being your humble
self here again I mean to get low enamel
because you carried a significant ammo
load oh yeah yeah so there was a lot
more contact here
you're using some animals yes you
weren't just shooting at Birds no I
called an airstrike end though okay when
we moved back into the perimeter I
called the air strike in and we had uh
l4s just eat that bottom up all that
whole valley where that crate was right
and uh
there's so much confusion
until I radioed Stone and I told them
we're low of ammo
I said I want helicopters in here we
need to get out of here I said have
there's no control of the hatchet Force
uh
we're in a mess we can't stay here
you've got to get us extracted and uh
he said I'll see what I can do
and uh
I
Let It Go for a while and then he came
back up and he said we can't get
aircraft into you today
I told him what's
uh
you've got the daylight in the morning
to get an aircraft in here if I don't
hear helicopter blades chopping in the
air
at daylight
I'm going to take all the Americans in
the Recon team and I'm leaving the
endidge here
the Hatcher Force I'm gonna
I'm gonna ene
with the Recon team
and the Americans the men you knew you
trusted
who actually fight when they see an
enemy and uh
Charlie Gray was on
relay at Leghorn and he
well up there would have been may have
been Hickory if you're coming up yeah
Hickory that's Charlie Gray knowing him
he's recovering from injuries that's why
they had him at the radio relay site
because he got wounded in an accident
somewhere right yeah in the in the
mountain that he was on the operation
going back in
after the attack sure uh Charlie got a
wounded there yeah his first of many but
uh he uh but anyway
uh I didn't sleep at all I mean I was I
was awake checking the perimeter we had
to endidge they had no idea what was
going on and not uh they're that poorly
trained
wow there's no no American supervision
tonight and no comma with you the Recon
team there to help out keep an eye out
for things
that's just well okay moving on with
that unbelievable story so the next
morning the helicopters came in and at
daylight and they
they lifted the entire force out
really and uh some of your beloved King
bees come in for that one or not just
regular confessed 100 first uh probably
100 it was you it's probably 100 first
yeah the Camp Eagle by 69. yeah but uh
uh
I don't know uh Captain Nicholson I
guess went back to his staff duty and
big Sia did and I don't know what
happened to
uh Master Sergeant oil
but uh that was a a fiasco
oh my God but I ran
uh
five more missions after that and
and then you're toward duty but we we
you and I have a personal thing we have
to get back to here
because in April of 69 my team
was given a mission at the mugia pass
to go up there and to go in heavily
fortified blah blah blah and that day
you're out there heckling us they took a
couple pictures which we use in our book
what I never realized was until you and
I were at the SFA reunion in San Antonio
like seven years ago
and you and I are talking about that
picture remember that day you're teasing
me remember that day and you were
hackling us we were getting our pictures
yeah oh yeah inspections General uh
Sarah Stillwell yeah still one yeah so
he's we were coming off off the mountain
yeah you that's right you were coming
off and then you just came by to
harasses
and you then you and I were talking to
San Antonio right right
they're very serious inspections sir
that picture looks so serious but it
they don't want to ever have any idea
somehow we didn't quite get you flipping
unless you're you're rapping your thing
but the reason the reason why I want to
return to this thing is our mission was
to go to the new year pass and so you
and I are in San Antonio talking over a
beer and you said by the way remember
that day and of course you and I were
laughing about that day because you were
harassing us getting our damn pictures
taken and you said what's the mission I
said well we're going to go up to mugia
pass for a couple days and go in heavily
and Bob trucks and do stuff like this
you go really they came to me I told him
to [__] off that's the suicide missing
we ain't doing it and you and I never
talked about it but that was one of
those missions that's a personal thing
between you and I yeah but oh my God but
also on a on a
day-to-day operational basis everything
was so compartmentalized that sometimes
we didn't talk enough yeah which would
be that example I mean NF would be one
we had a clubhouse we had our clubhouse
level before and now CCN where when the
guys came back they talked right but
right when it came to missions perhaps
what you had done
like with the Freshman did that mission
where they went in and blew up that NVA
fuel dump right you know they came back
they never talked about it some you know
the quiet professionals don't talk about
[__] unless you sit down
we should have discussed
with one another the one zeros
should have talked with one another
after every Mission yeah as a group
should have been an sop now we think
about it 51 years later should have been
yeah yeah indeed it's okay so I'm sorry
we just had that that a little sidebar
in life because I'll never forget I've
told so many people that story I told
chocolate is through you know I thought
they did it on tape or not but it's like
yeah we did this Mission you know and
then baby song comes we said [__] off
we're not doing that
but you had the experience and we were
still getting used to CCN we'd run some
other targets that were in layouts
across the border but that was a big one
and this is all new for us right and of
course you were you had much more wisdom
that you know than I did at that time
but uh
little did we say had we talked I would
say excuse me can you just maybe give
this to that the Nicholson [__] let
him go up there or something and stuff
it would have been
yeah indeed okay I'm sorry we got off
track so you wrap up your tour of Duty
as August you return you go back to brag
for Devin I go back to Fort Bragg uh
and this is August 69 now right and did
you get any leave when you went home
first yeah I took a leave go down to
Alabama check things out brought my wife
back to Fort Bragg uh in fact uh
I
I moved on post when I came back on post
housing
uh instead of I had a house in
Fayetteville when I took her back to
Alabama before deployed to Vietnam and
took the kids out of school and put them
back at Fort Bragg
and uh
I ended up in a seventh group sergeant
major McIntosh was the B Team sergeant
major he got orders for Charlie Gray and
several others from fob4
were in his B team right and Macintosh
just for the record was one of our
Sergeant Mayors who we all
worshiped because of his experience he
was with the 187th did a combat jump or
one or two into Korea right about time
he came to us he's a he's a sergeant
major
and nobody messed with him and he was
good he came to fubai first before he
came down to uh after we closed fubai he
came down with the Iceman
uh Colonel Jack Isla was the CEO and
Macintosh kicked ass and took numbers
right
but he was good he really listened to
the men now yes and you and him you and
him had a special report at some point I
hadn't I had no problem with him I mean
I I did my job and uh
there's a lot of guys if
if you're a slacker
Esther was trouble oh yeah
but uh if you're doing your jobs
everything's
good well yeah my favorite Macintosh
story this is a sidebar was
we were still at fubai and we just came
back out of the field and I'm going up
to the clubhouse to get sodas for the
guys
and he goes Meyer
why is your hair so long you got to get
a haircut so sorry sergeant major we've
been in the field I had a missing beard
but never mind continue on
he cared about the men in the mission
first none of that petty [__] from
camp
McIntosh was a super good leader uh well
then you've met with him so you had a
that part of your relationship with him
that you continued on with that after
you're in seventh group right uh
he had uh Charlie Gray
James Parker uh
uh MJ
uh what was MJ's last name MJ
eyes he's the fb4 guy before I got there
yeah uh so I need you from the clubhouse
right but anyway he had a bunch of us
from fob4 on the same a team right and
the rest
were uh spread out amongst the other uh
but the big majority of the 12
were guys from fob4 so again Mr
modesty's sitting here here's the
sergeant major for the entire company
says I want you guys here with me and
that's quite a that's a feather in your
cap brother well he he would uh he
wouldn't say it that way but that's what
that effect was he would uh
called Charlie and I up occasionally and
we'd have a shot of Jim Beam with him in
the evening
but uh Charlie
had
got an r r to uh Taiwan I think I think
he went to Taiwan he and two or three
other guys
uh got one of those uh C-130 maintenance
flights indeed and uh they were at the r
r Center and one day a couple of weeks
later sergeant major asked me he said
where's Charlie
two weeks later because r r is only five
days right so he left but two weeks
later Charlie uh Charlie
he said uh
where's Charlie and I said I don't know
it's hard the last I heard he was on r r
he said his rnr's over I said oh no
sorry major I've not seen Charlie
but he knew Charlie and I hung around
together but uh
he got to look he called the r r Center
and uh Charlie and I can't remember who
the guys were but anyway
they found out that if they reported to
the r r Center drunk they wouldn't let
them on the plane
to come back so every morning they came
in drunk they'd put on a uniform come to
catch the plane and they've been
drinking
sure so they spent another week yeah in
Taiwan for the sergeant major
called that r r Center and found out
what was going on and he told the guy
said in the morning when they report
you take their uniforms I don't care how
you do it gets security take their
uniforms don't let them leave the
building
in the morning
give them their uniforms back and put
them on the plane
and I didn't know Mr years later no what
had happened after we come back to
Bragg's already know you finally told
me what happened but uh
but uh
he was a good man but when Charlie Got
Back
he sent him to Leghorn oh yeah and uh on
the radio relay okay real estate where
you were
earlier in your tour of Duty after me to
it and he he uh
uh sergeant major left he D Rose
but I'd already D Rose because uh
I I left before the starting majorship
because
I was packing up to go because he came
at fob one like in the fall like October
or November and you came in country in
August right so you're at least a month
and a half two months ahead of his
one-year tour Duty in Vietnam so you're
going home Macintosh is now picking on
me and Lynn black
we're establishing our rapport with him
I'm I'm packed up to go on another
mission and
he walks
into my Hooch
and he says uh sergeant
where do you think you're going
I said I'm going on another mission
sergeant major
he put his hands on his shoulder
or as a waste and he said Sergeant your
your mission
is to take that web gear and that
rucksack
down the supply you've turned the well
the rucksack and keep your web gear
you're pulling gate guard for the next
14 days
and uh
you can go to the train
and eat all the ice cream cream you want
to you're going home to your family
you're not going on another minute no
kidding he knew about that your D Rose
was
yeah wow but they don't make Sergeant
marriage like that well maybe they do
hey with sfd we knew I was going to brag
he didn't I didn't know I was going to
brag till
talk about being last enough until I got
to yeah until they got to group I didn't
know I was going to Fort Bragg well
that's why I thought I was gone then we
wound up at 10th group it's like oh my
God I wanna never mind continue on sir
but uh and uh like all of us have orders
to the seventh group to a certain B team
and it was a sort of major Macintosh I
didn't know that until later because I
got sidetracked to G3 I was working at
Center
so have you made E6 yet are you still
Sergeant I made these six yeah uh in
Vietnam uh during that tour yeah can you
may have started saluting you because
your sixes and we were just e4s
but uh
anyway uh
he uh I hear this voice I've been
walking down the uh puzzle Palace
hallway and
I Heard a Voice Sergeant sergeant
I kept on sergeant and finally I turned
around and looked and it was sort of
major McIntosh coming down the hallway
oh wow and
he picked me up off the floor and hugged
me bear hoping he said boy what are you
doing here you're supposed to be in my B
team in the seventh group
and you see I said sorry may just set me
down
and we'll talk he did
and uh
he said your orders are to uh report
this was on a Friday he said on Monday
morning you'd be at building such and
such across from the center
uh for the big team formation
no kidding that's a sergeant major I
don't have orders he said I gave you
your orders the right written orders
will follow
and I've been trying I've been trying to
get on an 18 get back to an 18. yeah for
months and uh
he uh straightened it out got you on a B
team though in his B team but yeah and
then I was on The A Team
just for the record you can explain a
little bit the a teams or the action
teams B Teams support a at that time and
the C supports B but the whole supply
chain to keep the a teams moving and
that's why you wanted an a team as
opposed to B but when a sergeant made a
scarfs your ass up and goes your orders
will be here be there Monday morning
okay you're only in these six you don't
want to get busted E5 by saying no to
the sergeant major you just didn't say
no to McIntosh no no I never did for
sure but we uh uh and everything worked
out uh I stayed uh
a couple of years with uh
seventh group and a couple years yeah no
kidding and uh
Macintosh retired I might well maybe not
a couple of years maybe it's a year
because Macintosh retired and left the B
team and things changed drastically in
the company
and uh
I
I put in for reassignment to recruiting
Duty and really I went on recruiting
Duty for uh several years and then I
I said was that within the SF or was
that regular army regular armor
recruiting okay signed to Panama City
Florida
uh that's where the scuba team from the
seventh to come to do the refresher the
combat divers yeah sure yeah they came
there to every twice a year you're
running the Walt sumate down there yes
of course yeah all of them all of them
but he's the legend of our SF Legends
for combat divers right developed a
program and everything else what a just
a complete stud but I uh
uh
I'd always go out and dive with them
when they come down for a refresher is
that right they do one fine diver or two
and I'd go out and dive with them so go
from door gunner in the first cab now
you're becoming a combat diver in your
spare time in between recruiting
but uh
I kept in contact with everybody even
sergeant major McIntosh he uh he had
retired and uh
he called
me in Panama City to Florida
I said
Sergeant I want you to come to Fort
Bragg I want you to put my youngest son
in the army
really that's a sergeant major I'm in
Florida
I can't do that he says you can
ha and you will
and uh I I said all right sword major
I'll call uh uh recruiting headquarters
and I'll see what I can do
and I call the sword major at uh
Montgomery recruiting headquarters
and I told him the story and he said go
on take the car and go up there and put
it oh no kidding so I did and I put his
younger son in the army but uh then I
lost uh
see
I left recruiting Duty and went to back
to the Infantry in Alaska in Alaska is a
bad time you're in E7 I was 87 and I was
a student sergeant and
I was an e7p
and uh d7p yeah
and promotable yeah okay and uh
uh
I got promoted a year after I got
uh to Alaska and the amateur outfit I
was a platoon Sergeant for a year
and it got promoted first on
no kidding and uh
I had a daughter that came down with uh
uh cancer
and she had to have surgery and they
could only do the uh
after they did the surgery in Anchorage
I was in the sergeant majors Academy the
first starting course at the time that
she had to have surgery and they
couldn't do surgery until I came back to
Alaska
so I caught a plane back to Alaska and
they did her surgery
and uh
they had I had to take her to Augusta
Georgia Fort Gordon they reassigned me
to Fort Gordon because of
her treatment for radiation and chemo
that's a heck of a commute but
we moved to Fort Gordon and I was first
starting down there uh
and uh
uh she and passed away
and at that time I got selected for the
sergeant majors Academy
and I turned the uh Sergeant measures
Academy down and uh retired
after how many how many years all
together this was I was uh 20 20 okay
and uh
I uh
decided that uh
I didn't know where the assignment would
be at that time the sergeant majors came
and they didn't give you your uh
assignment what it was going to be until
uh to graduate wow and a week after I
turned it down and put my retirement
papers in
uh
I got a letter from General Schumacher
who had selected me for the sergeant
majors academy uh welcomed me to Delta
Force upon completion
no
and uh oh my God what year was this
cleat this was in uh
85 yeah wow yeah 65 20 years later 85
85. no kidding
oh my God you know I still have regrets
the the General's timing was uh
Yeah by a week yeah
well actually the Army's timing was off
because they should have told people
other than a general idea of where they
were going to be assigned because you
get two years additional
uh upon completion
on uh if you go to the sergeant majors
Academy you get two years right when you
get promoted you get two more years
so that would have put me to
uh 24 years
and I I just wouldn't do it without just
didn't feel like a real baby song after
20 years in the Army no no but the
assignment would have changed I think it
would have
would have been the uh
knowing where I was going sure would
have absolutely changed and you have
some other friends that we knew from CCN
days that were still involved that Delta
Force at that time absolutely one name
comes to mind in particular and I you
know I have a sneaky suspicion and he
was involved in in the assignment uh I I
you know I never did ask him or question
him right but uh our mutual friend Elton
bars well the first the one the only but
I I knew I do think he had it because we
contacted one another after I uh I moved
back to Alabama after I retired from the
Army and uh
I just uh
uh I got his telephone or no I got his
email address somehow and was he a proud
resident of Eufaula no no Alabama at
that time he was still up he was still
in Iraq oh is that okay sure and uh
I said you probably don't remember me
but uh in the message but uh it's a baby
sign oh yeah I'm just checking on you uh
find out when you're coming home and
they said oh I remember you like we all
do and yes and yes I'll be home next
month no kidding and I said uh
well where where are you coming to
he said uh
my family
is moving moving to uh Eufaula
and uh but I'm gonna be assigned
to Fort Bragg for retirement purposes
and uh
he uh
he came home and
they were at Bragg for his retirement
now
he called them and invited he invited
all the saw guys that he knew back to
Bragg for his retirement and we all
showed up at his retirement it was it
was but that was another 20 years later
in 2005. right yeah but you got out in
85 right and you're you suspected him of
course that's such a Class Act he would
never say a word but he would try
because he knew you're a good Troop
and he had a lot of involvement with
Delta Force for years oh yeah my God he
was in the second class because he
disappeared from the seventh grade
and and
we didn't know where he went
and he ended up in delta pick a number
from a to d as in delta
yes indeed well um so from there after
your army career you did what for a
little bit there and then we'll head on
down back to Alabama I uh
I got a job with security at nuclear
security at the Savannah River nuclear
weapons plan and uh
I
went on terminal leave
and
uh
the colonel
that'll work for
at Fort Gordon and called me and asked
me he said would you help
move some uh
uh there's a fundraiser for a lady
in Aiken South Carolina
that needs some help moving some stuff I
want you to come out here
to Fort Gordon and uh
take responsibility for moving all this
stuff they're putting on a play or
something and she wants to move all that
stuff I'll give you the detail and you
can go out and do it
and I did
and uh
I made a the lady worked at the Savannah
nuclear weapons plant at the
headquarters of the uh
it wasn't uh didn't she didn't have
anything to do with security but I told
when I moved the stuff for
the detail and she was happy and uh
invited me to come down
to the plant and eat lunch with her and
I the next day and I did
and I told her I'd uh I ate lunch with
her during the meal I told her I'd
applied for security at the nuclear
weapons plant
and she said you did and I said yes but
I've not heard from him and she picked
up the phone and uh
got an appointment connections again got
an appointment for me with a employment
of
uh
the security yeah and next day I went
and filled out all the paperwork and did
the polygraph test and
uh the next week I started nuclear no
kidding
and my first assignment I was working
with a
a retired sergeant major craft he was a
shift supervisor
of where I was assigned to be a security
officer
and I went to uh
worked for him and they do a test they
do a test of security of the nuclear
plant
they bring in teams from Delta Force
and Ron Owens the people like that yeah
yeah Verona but uh he uh
and I didn't know where you had anything
to do with any of that until you uh
years later but uh
they came in to do the test and I was my
post during the test we had the Shadow
Force with the
we always carried live ammo uh on all
the security positions inside the uh
plant area oh yeah but uh
when they do that test with the Delta
Force
uh
we had blanks and that we they'd put the
uh uh what do you call the uh
electronic gear uh miles gear
that goes off since your rifle to put an
attachment that shoots the laser beam
right it sets off the miles gear we all
aware of that and so does so do the
Delta Force guys
and uh
I was on the roof of the building the
night of the test
uh will the machine gun and I saw the
guys coming uh
off the corner of the plant through the
fence
and they climb into a flatbed truck
pulled a tarp over them three of them
getting a cab of the truck and I called
in to report to the
uh shift leader I spotted the uh
Intruders
they're headed towards the main building
I'm taking them on the fire at this time
and I opened up with a machine gun I got
the three guys in in DeKalb and uh
I was picking them off one at a time by
that time as they come out from under
the tarp uh
and
at that as by that time this uh Roven
patrols had blocked them in there's two
ten foot fence and two patrol cars
behind them and they killed the rest of
them and
the game's over
wow but they put them inside the plant
and then they had to they were going to
try to break out
and the guy come up he turned his miles
gear off but I blazed him with that M60
and I just set the M60 down I said this
guy's just turned off give me a live
ammo he'd be dead
and uh I'm accustomed a little and uh
the uh lieutenant in charge of overalls
on charge of security I tried to settle
me down some and uh
the working Hood
manager out of Florida
as president of wacking up security
I carried my machine gun off the off the
building for me
next day I got promoted to a shift
supervisor and they sent me to uh
uh the separation point at the nuclear
facility as shelf supervisor
and they had never passed
this security test one had been tested
by Delta and uh
uh I'd been there about two two or three
months so all that time and your
experience as a door gunner came into
really good play there
you're a natural that's weird that's
weird yeah no kidding but uh they came
in to test it so I I always grew up in
the plant I'd check my posts
three or four times during the shift but
we did alternating shifts mornings uh
morning shift evening shift and midnight
shift
but uh on you they always did the test
on midnight shift but I would always go
up in the plant and I knew the operators
the civilian operators
uh with the Department of energy because
I'd sit and eat lunch with them and sure
I got to know you know how to build team
rapport
and that was a part of security
absolutely and uh and I got to know him
you know my first name and when I'd walk
through they'd know they'd wave or they
just called um60
well we got tests we were the first uh
team to be test tested that beat him get
there well yeah we did that's so cool
but I I sat down with the one of the
guys a day before
uh we were to be tested
and eat lunch with him I asked him I
said you know strangers have been around
here lately
uh anything strange going on in the
building he said yeah there's two guys
came through here yesterday
I said word
ly spend most of their time they said
well they went to the door down the hall
that way and then they went down to the
uh one down the hallway by the uh main
separation point
and
so there was only two places
I knew who it was and it was only two
places that they could enter that plant
and that was the two places and I
doubled up Security on it the night of
the uh
uh the test test
and they had a reaction forced by
helicopters in the air that you could
call in really at any time that you
needed them the doe assets you had and
any King bees
they had a little a little lighter light
helicopters now before sell the cop but
uh
anyway uh
they uh
the thing went off and uh
they did hit that door inside the
building and I I sent the Rovers in
behind them and they brought another
security officer in and they killed all
of them right there at that one door Wow
first time that and I uh
I uh
resigned that night
and move back to Alabama really yeah
oh my God so you moved back to Alabama
and what what happened from here on
because by now you have at least one
pension I retired and for a while I went
to school for two years for the GI Bill
and uh what kind of learning were you
getting there Woodworking and cabinet
Mike
oh no kidding yeah really and uh
I never did applied well I bought a
house and we finished it up on the
inside and I built the cabinets and did
all the woodwork inside a wood Craftsman
and indeed well I put the
money to use indeed experience but uh
uh
after I got the house built I started uh
I got an offer on a job selling meat to
grocery stores and I called on a Bruno's
account in a large
grocery company in Birmingham Alabama
and they had grocery stores in five
states
and my they put me on
a team to go set up brand new grocery
stores all we did was move from one new
store to another set it up on the day
that the grocery store opened uh we'd
move to another new store and get it
ready wow it took us about a week or 10
days to set it up for grand opening
grand opening days we'd move to the next
one I have opened
uh 150 grocery stores and
in seven years that's a lot of meat
peddling yeah but uh that's a whole lot
of meat yeah but uh
then I totally retired
after that I totally retired
so is that around that period of time
where we had the Special Operations
Association you found time to be
director for a couple tours of Duty you
were president for a while I had uh and
uh lived happily ever after well I
hadn't met Deborah and married her and
we were living in in column in my
hometown and
uh one day we bought a computer and one
day I'm sitting there playing on the
computer and I just typed in sog
and up Pops
all you guys names no and uh
and contact information on some and I
contacted Lynn black right I may have
contacted
you I don't know but I that's so long
about long-term memory stuff brother but
they told me about they told me about
SOG and all this stuff and yeah
the rest is history the rest is history
well we're getting to that point where
we've been chatting for a little while
here
um before we shut down any final
thoughts or cogitations or ruminations
that you might have sir
[Music]
um
this is probably
I don't know where the highlight of my
life will be
but
this uh
this little trip here
with these Special Forces soldiers and
we solicitate we should illuminate where
we are we are in Fort outside of Fort
Bragg outside and you and I and other
SOG men had the privilege of visiting
third Special Forces Group that had a
SOG Symposium SOG heritage
a three-day event and we're in the
middle of that right now kicked off this
morning Monday November the 8th and 9th
and 10th and we have a chance to meet
these young Special Forces men who
carried forward in the mission who are
incredible
as well as some of the command elements
and then tomorrow some guys are going
out to the range to see the latest boy
toys are
and in the meantime they get to talk to
the old gray heads like you and I that
spent a little time on the ground SOG
and it's amazing and the highlight of
that of the mountain ours are coming
tomorrow indeed the highlight of the day
for sure so uh with that thought in mind
any other final thoughts sir no well
that was we're at that point where we
close out we again we always thank Jocko
willing productions for making this all
possible for he and his staff
and as always we thank all of our
military our border patrol First
Responders emergency personnel
that help to keep our country going in
these days parents that are fighting for
their freedoms here in America
we also thank the men and the women
who served our country in years past
Heroes like you Clete complete sineyard
AKA baby song a true Soldier a great man
and we also remember and salute the men
and the women who aren't here today
who today in Vietnam alone as you and I
remember there are
1584 missing in action 550 of which are
Green Berets alone from the secret war
and another 83 aviators who died
supporting us on the ground at that time
We Salute them and again we thank Jocko
for his production until next time God
Bless America thank you teal Airborne
brother